what's going on Rob this is guys and we
are back with nightcrawlers so this
opens in one of the coolest ways ever
right the sense of sinister story is
phenomenal so what we end up finding out
here is that where the night crawlers
were originally introduced to us as what
were by all standards of measurement
kind of like the Assassins of the
original Mr Sinister Nathaniel Essex
that in the first video that we did we
found that over time the nightcrawlers
started to break away from his influence
and so what ended up happening is that
defecting from Mr Sinister they started
allying themselves with Mother righteous
who was another clone of sinister that
existed out there now by and large she
had just kind of been hands off she was
watching everything unfold the original
quiet Council so the original leaders of
the X-Men who were influenced by the
diamond sinister's power ultimately
defecting taking over from him and then
kind of launching a conquest of the
universe that one of the things that we
find is that over time while that was
happening right that when the first
video took place 10 years later this one
taking place a hundred years later that
in that 90-year window the universe has
become a very dark place the forces of
magic who have basically again broke
away from control of sinister has been
launching a conquest and in fact tried
to bring the magical realm or the
Demonic realm of limbo into the main
Marvel Universe and didn't succeed right
that one of the things Xavier did as the
really like the villainous version of
himself he traveled to the Shia Empire
right their Homeworld and used his
telepathy to convince them that
everybody was out to get them and
basically drove the Shia empire into a
state of Civil War where they all
started killing each other while you
have the forces of Asgard which are
always at war with any other race that's
out there because it's trying to remain
in isolation that there's a point where
other world right so King Arthur and all
those guys that Empire basically starts
to crumble and fall due to no protection
coming from the X-Men or anything the
universe as a whole is quite literally
completely and totally falling apart and
it's really interesting to see that
because the X-Men went from being Heroes
to being villains that they've led to
this full-scale conquest and collapse of
reality as we know it in terms of any
real real organizational structure
across the universe as a whole it's a
very dark and Bleak place but through
all of that what the night crawlers have
been doing in the service of mother
righteous if they've been kind of
hopping and skipping through these
different events and stealing particular
artifacts right stealing small little
things in the midst of this giant battle
between like Loki and the asgardians and
whatever Force happens to be out there
the night crawlers teleport in steal an
artifact and then teleport out and so
what it does is it focuses on Asgard
proper that what they're doing is
they're hunting for an artifact
specifically they're hunting for the
hammer of Thor and that when they get
there Thor immediately turns on them and
then tries to attack them but understand
the night crawlers at least Kurt Wagner
by himself just a guy is probably the
most prodigious assassin that Marvel
Comics has but you never see him operate
in that way but what ends up happening
is that because you have Laura Kinney
x-23 who was basically merged with the
Nightcrawler Gene it's effectively a
version of Wolverine who can teleport
like Nightcrawler she still has the
adamantium laws so she overcomes Thor
like that I mean in the blink of an eye
slices his arm off and that's basically
it now because they can't actively lift
his hammer what they end up doing is
they end up having one of the other
members of what are called the Knight
can basically and a different name for
the night crawlers that what they do is
they use their ability to manipulate
gravity to control where the hammer goes
now that's not uncommon and in fact
that's been a thing in Marvel Comics for
years ever since Magneto first Fought
The Avengers we've seen people who have
been able to use the fundamental
properties of the electromagnetic
spectrum or gravity or what have you to
manipulate the hammer of Thor but what
we end up doing is transitioning over to
Vox ignis who again is basically uh Sean
Cassidy Banshee with the power of kind
of a Ghost Rider basically by all
standards the measurement it has a
different name and a history but it is
in effect one of the Ghost Rider spirits
that ended up becoming a good guy but
the important thing here is that it is
Banshee within immense level of power
but he doesn't really do a whole lot
here so it's not overly important to
understand his character what he does do
is he go those and he talks to Laura
Kenny and what she says is that her
former husband basically is undergoing
What's called the last right right
that's summer night which is what he's
called she says he's losing his battle
against the diamond Sinister is retaking
control a great trauma can have that
effect now here's why that matters
because one of the things we learned is
that when Sinister created the
nightcrawlers that he intentionally bred
infertility into them meaning that they
cannot procreate or they should not be
able to but much like the dinosaurs from
Jurassic Park life finds a way and what
ended up happening is Laura Kinney x-23
and the Nightcrawler Cyclops ended up
having a baby the problem is the baby
suddenly teleported out right it
literally just disappeared seemingly out
of nowhere and what it looked like is
that its powers manifested at Birth and
teleported away but the kicker to this
is that while Laura seemed to be able to
get past it or at the very least was
kind of like you know I've endured pain
and torment and Trauma before that
Nightcrawler Cyclops was not able to do
the same and has effectively just become
a drunk right his pain in losing his
child has just gotten the worst of it
and so the result of this is he
undertakes what's called the last right
in the sense that it's ritualistic
suicide and what happens is that he
literally teleports to essentially the
force field that surrounds all the
morimiktaggarts in the hopes that like
his sacrifice will bring the force field
down now that's something that I want
you to keep in the back of your head one
because we're kind of doing this in
segments right so instead of doing an
issue by issue and Order we're doing the
night crawlers then Immortal X-Men or
immoral X-Men and so on and so forth so
based on the videos we find it might be
a smidge out of order here but that
whole ritualistic sacrifice is something
that I want you to keep in mind because
one of the things that happens is that
Sean Cassidy and having this
conversation with Laura Kinney she
starts asking these questions right she
says we're running low on the Flesh of
Cortez to extend our leaps because
people who are familiar with the X-Men
know Fabian Cortez is a mutant that has
the ability to amplify the powers of
mutants around him and so with the
inability to clone mutants the same way
uh Sinister was that the ability to use
the abilities of Fabian Cortez are
running low so they won't be able to
teleport as far as as long as things
stay on this current course the other
part of that is that without the ability
to procreate and with the nightcrawlers
teleporting in ritualistic suicide due
to this last right basically the ending
of their lives their numbers are running
low in essence the night crawlers are
basically going extinct and so if for no
other reason for self-preservation you
have Laura Kinney who says you need to
go ask a question to Mother righteous in
order for us to get a definitive answer
and what Sean Cassidy says and this is
something that's really important too is
he says he does talk to Mother righteous
but she always approaches people and
always asks the same question if you
could do things over what would you have
done differently now one of the
instances where she asked this question
is to Legion now remember a legion is an
Omega Level mutant I mean this guy's got
thousands of personalities each one with
a power of its own but he also has the
ability to alter reality now within the
Legion of X comic books where the mother
righteous was initially introduced one
of the things that Legion had done is he
basically created a pocket Universe
where he could bring the spiritual
essence of different mutants in and they
could live a life or live some measure
of escape from the reality of the world
that they lived in what he's done here
is that continuing this dimensional
realm this pocket Universe he created
that he literally brought the X-Men that
he could save to this place so they left
their physical bodies behind and their
spiritual Essence remains here but it
seems to kind of be the larger part of
Legion himself they kind of absorb them
into himself and as he's talking to
Mother righteous what he effectively
says is if I could do it all over again
I never would have trusted you I never
would have believed you I never would
have let you get your clutches and
introduced you to the X-Men the way that
I did such as it is there's only one
thing that I can do and it's to Simply
leave to a higher plane of existence now
the crazy thing about this is that where
x23 is hearing a story she initially
sees the original Legion as a person
that could save them and he could given
the level of power that he has at his
disposal he could fix everything in an
instant but he's become disillusioned
with the entirety of not just the mutant
population but the universe has a a
whole why save a place that you believe
simply just deserves to die that you
don't care about anymore and so he
ultimately takes off we don't know where
he goes to and we ultimately never find
out the important thing here is that x23
has Sean Cassidy talked to Mother
righteous for the purpose of allowing
the nightcrawlers to go on a mission and
what they end up doing is they basically
teleport back to Earth which is now just
become this really dark and crappy place
that's just been run amok with all the
experiments of sinister that are
constantly evolving and constantly
changing albeit without any real measure
of sentience of their own and they in
turn get to the Xavier Institute right
the the place where the X-Men used to
reside and they find Dr Nemesis there
now Dr Nemesis under normal
circumstances right James Bradley he's
just a guy that has an incredible level
of intelligence but due to the
experimentation of sinister over time
he's basically kind of infused with what
is in effect fungal matter and what this
has done is allowed him to expand this
fungal matter across the entirety of the
world and is also expanded his
intelligence to go along with it so he's
like this just astronomically genius
being more so than he ever was before
but the reason for the X-Men being there
at least the nightcrawlers being there
is because once they teleport back the
kind of situation they present to Mother
righteous is that using the intelligence
of Dr Nemesis they can find some way to
start cloning more nightcrawlers and
continue the propagation and the
existence of their race now something to
understand here is x-23 making this
declaration and presenting this entire
scenario to Mother righteous it was
effectively a ruse she basically won on
the mission with ulterior motives there
was the public motive she gave which is
we need to find a way so that the night
crawlers can continue to exist so we can
continue serving you right you know in
an honorable fashion as our religious
leader and so on and so forth the
reality here is she teleported down to
earth so she could grab the original
Nightcrawler who's long since been
mutated and has just kind of run its
evolutionary course so that he can show
up here and kill mother righteous and
the reason why is because what mother
righteous does from a religious
perspective and we'll talk more about
this here in a second because I feel
like the religious motivations of her
character are a lot more clear in the
third issue than the second issue but
when she kind of pitched herself as this
religious leader she kept talking about
the spark right the spark of the of of
the mutant population and so on and so
forth but the reason why I say this is
that the spark as it was originally
introduced in Marvel Comics was a
concept by Nightcrawler that was a
colloquial term for Faith right keep the
spark alive keep the faith alive right
keep the belief alive that kind of a
thing right it was kind of a way to say
like we're the ones who keep the faith
strong we're the heroes we do the good
thing that kind of a situation what
mother Rogers has done here is corrupted
and basically use it for her own ends
the spark is you doing whatever it is
that I tell you to do because I'm your
religious leader that's basically what
she's done and so when the original
Nightcrawler shows up here he's angry at
her because of the fact that she has
basically perverted what the spark is
supposed to represent but mother
righteous in no uncertain terms kills
this guy on the spot right literally
wipes him out and he's referred to as
the apostate right the guy who defied
the will of mother righteous tried to
kill the religious leader and so with
the death of Nightcrawler x-23 tries to
jump in and then in turn mother
righteous snaps her fingers and then
submits x-23 to just an astronomical
amount of mental pain but that turns out
to be the nail in the coffin for mother
righteous and it happens in two
different ways the first is because she
tells the other night kin to basically
wrap up the apostate and then send him
toward his own Doom right to experience
the last right which is basically
teleporting him into the force field
surrounding the murmaid Taggarts and the
hopes that they can basically break
through the other reason why this is a
big deal is because in the moment when
x23 is being tortured by mother
righteous what happens is she gets a
glimpse of the daughter that she
believed to have been dead only to find
out that mother righteous is actually
holding her prisoner but we also get
this insane moment right because with
issue number three we jump forward a
thousand years and what we end up
finding out here is somewhere along the
line and we don't know how this happened
and we're not given any explanation as
to how it happened Absalon Mercator had
basically merged or somehow become a a
combination person with the Silver
Surfer now the Silver Surfer most all of
you guys know who that is but Mr M is an
Omega Level mutant with the power to
warp reality so it would be like if
Franklin Richards in the Silver Surfer
merged right just a crazy level of power
so much so that what the ad what the the
silver Mercator was doing was traveling
around the universe and unstitching the
lokies from reality literally wiping
them from existence removing them from
the universe now this has happened in a
variety of ways and among a variety of
different people different sinisters
were overcome by The Brood horde which
are basically the Marvel Comics version
of the aliens right the xenomorph movie
that kind of thing Sigourney Weaver and
all that it's their version of that more
or less right the two kind of run hand
in hand but mother righteous herself
still continues on with this idea of
trying to find a way to attain What's
called the reliquary perilous as well as
breaking through the force field of the
more mctaggarts now this is where all
the stuff we've been talking about
starts to get cleared up so mother
righteous with regard to her religious
convictions positions herself as the
religious leader of the night crawlers
but the reality is she doesn't care
anything about them she sees them as a
means to an end but what she'd learned
over the course of her time is nothing
will convince people to do something
like religious Faith right it's like
that line from The Book of Eli when Gary
oldman's character is talking about the
nature of the nature of the Bible and he
says it's a tool to control the weak and
the desperate and that's how mother
righteous uses religion here that you
have all these nightcrawlers who have
just have these grotesque physical
appearances because without the ability
to clone the original Nightcrawler
they're making clones out of clones out
of clones right so you have Laura Kinney
who is a clone of Nightcrawler or kind
of a chimera of Nightcrawler they clone
Laura Kinney which has her own set of
problems but they cloned that clone and
they cloned that clone so on and so
forth so you run into this situation
where you have these grotesque and
mutated versions of Nightcrawler but it
doesn't matter to her because the only
real purpose they serve is to basically
commit ritualistic suicide that whenever
one of them show up here and they say
mother I have to apologize I've heard
Talk of the apostate and like the false
prophet right so Nightcrawler the
original Nightcrawler that tried to kill
mother righteous and the false prophet
basically x-23 who tried to kill mother
righteous that whenever they hear talk
about this and they tell mother
righteous about that in order to remove
anybody that may even begin to Harbor
the idea that she's not telling the
truth she basically uses the religious
conviction through words and saying it's
okay my child take the last right and
you will be forgiven of your sins and
they teleport themselves to Suicide it's
pretty dark man it's really really dark
it's a horrible thing to do and what's
so crazy about this is again she doesn't
believe anything she's saying she's
doing it one part because it gains her
power and two just because she can right
she's doing it for no other reason than
the fact that she can and it basically
creates willful servants that are just
too naive to ask any questions of her
right by seeding out and removing any
measure of dissent that now she has this
almost kind of group of people that
follow her with no pun intended a
religious fervor and so in the midst of
this conversation or where she sends
this this Nightcrawler off to die again
she has what's called a Phoenix egg
which can potentially Harbor allow for
the birth of a phoenix you know the
Phoenix returning to a particular house
again this all kind of goes into the
reliquary perilous so you're not going
to see anything crazy which we will
explain what the perilous is but she's
talked to by Dr Nemesis who has long
since left Earth but become this giant
fungal organism but what he's done is
he's taken his ability to control fungal
organisms and now he's able to see and
hear everything Across the Universe and
what he tells her is that the original
Mr Sinister has basically resurfaced now
we know this just by virtue of the
events that have transpired in the
immoral X-Men comic which is really
really cool if you guys haven't seen our
video on that you'll find a link to it
down in the comments section but what
mother righteous says here is that she's
largely been hands off she's been
focusing on her own little scheme over
here and the diamond X-Men and all the
other X-Men out there have been Waging
War against each other trying to conquer
the universe and so on and so forth and
she started to realize there's a much
bigger event at play here and it all
comes down to Destiny now that's been a
common theme that we've talked about in
The Sims of sinister story that Destiny
is a precognitive she can see the future
if she tells you something's gonna
happen in 500 years take it with a grain
of salt if she tells you something's
gonna happen in five minutes take it as
an absolute truth and so she kind of
touches on some of the events that have
transpired over time that Mystique
ultimately ended up dying that the
entire motivation behind Destiny doing
everything she did in this universe was
to try to find some measure of a life
with Mystique but the reality here is
that because Mystique felt like like she
was caged it was only a matter of time
before she went out to fight the
oppressors and was ultimately killed but
with the death of Mystique her being the
wife of Destiny the response of Destiny
is then reasonably reset the timeline
and that's basically it right now that
my love interest is gone and there's
nothing here for me anymore now we do
the right thing we set the universe back
to the way that it's supposed to be by
killing one of the mara clones but of
course as we know from the storm and the
Brotherhood of mutant storyline she was
killed right she was literally cut in
half at the direction of storm herself
right this desire to keep this universe
going to keep this universe alive and so
what ends up happening here is Mother
righteous is told by Dr Nemesis there is
an object that is heading towards the
Mormon tadrants right this in this
impenetrable force field that nobody
seems to be able to access and when
mother righteous realizes what it is she
realizes this was set in motion by
Destiny thousands of years ago like a
thousand years ago when the sins of
sinister story first kicked off and so
what she does is she brings together all
the night crawlers she has she has the
trumpet sounded they all teleport into
the impenetrable force field and they're
all killed right they're all eradicated
and so the only other thing that she
does is she basically brings in what's
called Auntie Fortune now Auntie Fortune
was at the beginning of simsa sinister a
Nightcrawler that had been merged with
Domino and as those of you guys who are
familiar with Domino from Marvel Comics
know she has the ability to Bend luck in
her favor and this is the reason why
mother righteous always has the brain of
Auntie Fortune around her because no
matter what happens things will always
happen to fall in her in inner favor
luck will always be on her side and her
being here is no different because what
happens is that in watching all of this
transpire you suddenly have a Ghost
Rider imbued Galactus who arrives on the
scene and it's amazing to see because
when that happens right Banshee shows up
and says like Yes somewhere along the
line we don't know how it happened and
honestly we never find out how it
happened all the different spirits of
Vengeance that had escaped Earth at the
rise of the forces of sinister bonded
themselves to Galactus now all of this
seems to be predicated on the fact that
Galactus being a being of hunger was
Hunger for vengeance against the mutant
population for everything they had done
to the universe but whatever the
motivation is it's a being traveling
around the universe with the powers of
the Ghost Rider wiping out everything in
his path and so where you do have Sean
Cassidy that says we have to step in and
do something the response of mother
righteous is no she says a thousand
years ago the sinisters shot an
Unstoppable object right through the
brain of a Titan they didn't stop to
wonder where it would go next but
Destiny did Destiny knew now if you guys
remember at the very beginnings of the
sins of sinister's story the first one
shot that we got that you had the island
of krakowa that literally had a giant
tree that could the the mutant
population could talk to what ended up
happening is that in an effort to
lobotomize the krakowan island and take
away its control allowing the X-Men free
reign to operate as they wanted to under
the influence of sinister they shot the
Juggernaut through its head and what she
says is a millennium of gravity Wells
slingshots infinitesimal changes of
course building speed becoming light and
time screaming in the Silence of the
vacuum unable to die unable to stop
madder than a box of otters while she
tweaked the path of the world Farm
setting up a cosmic trick shot an
impossible conjunction enter the
Juggernaut and the Juggernaut smashes
through the head of Galactus like bam
now this is the cool thing about this
Destiny said all this in motion she said
everything in motion and this is why I
say this is why Destiny is such a cool
character because a thousand years ago
Destiny looked at what was going to
happen in the future and said okay the
X-Men are most likely gonna do this this
is most likely what's gonna happen
that's most likely what's gonna happen
so in order to ensure everything
transpires the way it's supposed to I
will do this this this this and this and
move these pieces around in this way so
that at the right time the Juggernaut as
he was shot into space by the X-Men what
ultimately smashed through the head of
Galactus and in doing so puncture a hole
through the impenetrable force field of
the Mora mctaggarts right the right
place at the right time that's how
capable of a precognitive Destiny is and
so the result of this is that with the
more mittaggart force field basically
being blown wide open it allows mother
righteous to enter with the reliquary
perilous now here's the funny thing
about the reliquary perilous that the
way she pitched it to the night crawlers
the way she billed into the night
crawlers it's an artifact of
unimaginable Powers the thing in which
we worship and it's a thing that we
value that's never what it was she was
using it as a tool against the night
crawlers in order to game their faithful
service the nature of the reliquary
perilous is that it's a time capsule
that when she went around and she was
asking all these people if you could
change anything what would you change
she would take their answers and she
would confine it in the reliquary
perilous she knows it's only a matter of
time between before somebody resets the
entirety of the universe by killing one
of the mirrors remember the power of
Maureen mctaggard is every time she dies
the universe resets now the goal of
mother righteous was to grab all these
different artifacts all these different
bits of power how these different things
work where to gain these little pieces
of power right to even take things like
the Phoenix egg and so on confine it
into what's basically a time capsule and
send it back through the time stream and
then kill one of the moiras herself and
reset reality so that when the time came
because mother righteous is a clone of
sinister and because she was around 200
years before the events of sins of
sinister ever took place that what she
would be able to do is she could send
the artifact to herself and then she
would gain an astronomical amount of
power and she'd be able to basically
conquer existence she could make the
universe whatever she wanted it to be
using the power of the Phoenix egg so on
and so forth making herself a host for
the Phoenix force with the power of Thor
all that kind of cool stuff but of
course what ends up happening here is
that with Banshee realizing the goal of
mother righteous was never to try to
find a way to preserve the entirety of
this universe but to actually kidnap the
child of x-23 so it can be used for
really even race for a mother righteous
own ends in the distant past to
basically send all that back and
effectively Wipe Out the universe that
Banshee has the same motivation that
storm did in storm of the Brotherhood
where she basically made this argument
in saying that yes this universe is
awful but those who are native to this
universe who were born into this
universe they all have the right to try
to find the best possible life they can
and that by wiping this universe out
we're taking that away from them we're
dooming countless billions or trillions
of people and so in that moment he tries
to attack mother righteous now when that
happens she strips some of his power and
with him basically being powerless
that's when x23 jumps in with the
intention of attacking mother righteous
now she is able to hear hit her
momentarily but of course using her own
power mother righteous is able to
overcome x23 but in that moment Shaun
Cassidy looking to atone for all of his
actions over the course of sins of
sinister ends up stabbing mother
righteous as a distraction and once that
distraction comes in Acts 23 stabs
mother righteous through the test with
her tail and kills her on the spot and
so when it's all said and done basically
Laura gets her daughter and then
teleports away right she gets her child
and just takes off and that's basically
it banshees just kind of left there
dying into kind of atone for his actions
the reliquary perilous is just sitting
there on the ground and ultimately what
ends up happening is the true Mora
McTaggart arrives and seizes it for
herself all indications being she's
gonna do exactly what mother righteous
did which is find a way to send the
heart back to herself kill herself reset
the timeline and then attain absolute
power because lest we forget one of the
things we learn in Jonathan Hickman's
run on the X-Men in Inferno is that in
order to save the mutant population the
goal of Maura McTaggart was to eliminate
all the mutant powers and the mutant
Gene itself while preserving the lies of
anybody who was a mutant in effect
making every mutant human whether that
works or not we don't fully know but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later
peace